going wrist my name is Pippa and welcome
back to lost delight we sure that lost
them
it's so dark sorry about that
sorry about your nipple okay okay okay I
don't know
hey guys nope we've been in here no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know that which
gotta happen in yeah don't come in here
don't come in here and don't come in
here
get up yeah Oh God come on
we're fine
oh [ __ ] seriously give me a [ __ ] Jew
don't touch me dr. Chen Mei
are we good
give me a break
I didn't do anything dad ass dad [ __ ]
us okay
[Music]
well [ __ ] it let's do it oh [ __ ] anyway
setting work they didn't wait that
didn't work that didn't work
oh wait I got this I'm a pro I'm a pro
why the [ __ ] did I do that
okay where's the cellar I just got to
find itself okay no no no this is the
dead-end [ __ ] okay that's fine it's fine
are you
come on well I'm camping here
oh come on no now what am I supposed to
do you follow me everywhere it's not
nice
seriously don't look at me like that I
did what I could
I should have taken the right but
probably well at least we know where to
go
actually um but hey that's life right
yeah
that's life you [ __ ] era okay so we
run past the gangbang garden as I like
to call it ah that's a nice gangbang
look shut up jump on the gangbang
hopefully he isn't here anymore sweaty
as a bus you didn't do anything well
maybe this is it that was it I'm an
idiot all right whoa oh [ __ ] it's
collapsing I am running
aren't you supposed to not take
elevators oh this is a step okay why is
it blinking white and so annoying go got
pants got pants no no no no I'm an idiot
okay go up gym code up cue card up Holly
[ __ ] I shoulda ate it's already [ __ ]
hot pockets is this taking forever
I'm so fat come on come on come on come
on come on buck these the game is saved
you can reload the scene
thank you what are we doing here that
what is going on
oh he's telling me I can replay that if
I want to but I don't have to why would
I you do that that makes no sense at all
damn it what a collapse collapses so
suddenly yeah it was
I was pretty suddenly damn it yeah ah we
made it prize boxer hello oh shut up no
not him not him
oh [ __ ] just kidding right like about
John like about that but oh I'm not
ready for a water part we're fine right
fine
[ __ ] that water [ __ ]
left eye we're not fight we're not
fighting right we're not fight let us
fight without fighting we're not fine
Hey
oh yeah that I'm glad I'm going through
all this [ __ ] it's going like a bomb
keep going about it go put this what no
I'm screwed I don't know where the lever
is hi hi hi hi hi hi calm down calm down
calm down okay we're good we're fine
we're not fine okay
where is it what is this lever you speak
up seriously where is it well it's gotta
be back here
like a vodka run like a
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba question
go back there oh you're so hungry what
item did you but so he's technically
really small is that it oh I can jump
over there's something on the other side
shut up
I'm thinking shut up I like splashing -
but you're taking it too far bro stop
stop oh baby oh baby mamas okay genius
boots very Jess look at that let us know
that black death
[Music]
all right so we pull the lever run out
of oil
oh wait I have oh don't worry don't even
think about it bullet pull it to the
limit walk along the razor's head throw
a box and you are dead you could do our
hair don't know which way to go i [ __ ]
out probably this way I don't remember
this is the wrong way
don't kill me please thank you I like a
bow I think I gotta pull this again
actually I would never have made that
okay I should have run the right way in
the first place well [ __ ] you live in
your land okay hey I like splashing -
[ __ ] you ha hi Don
dumb like a boss jump like a jump yes
yeah you stay air battles Oh baby oh no
another one come on hey hey hey don't
push me brah
oh oh so close huh it's so unnerving
that flash can act as I didn't see any
dead flesh did you see any Fred flash a
flash flash flash dead flash flash no
flash Padma well I nearly made it anyway
it's not like it matters
okay Daniel oh [ __ ] oh come on I should
have taken the ladder than that what
keep out of there what it'd be nice okay
it's not easy
daddy don't be nice what see if I care
I have a torso tenor you suck at this
game shut up Chuck yup okay why do we do
[Applause]
okay oh thank god we're out of this
hellhole [ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's gonna give me a heart attack one of
these days bread discuss the story so it
doesn't give you a break
except when you love GLaDOS applause
love walking ladders not gonna lie I'm a
big fan of ladder I like them on
Facebook I'm actually their fan leaning
ladders great thing to like I don't see
why you don't like them wait this
doesn't make sense is this up or down oh
my head
who put you here seriously you're not
supposed to smoke weed here hollow
needle well don't mind if I do appears
brother I got des yeah that just got it
just gotta fight it penetrate right
through that no luckily I have two days
okay they say the second time is the
charm
just get it no seriously
all right third times it's the pins oh
shut up shut up
you're not talking but I'm seeing a tit
okay [ __ ] that [ __ ]
so mean to me oh all of this well you
know what I'm going out going in there
I'm going over
because I have this nice mapping brow
that's dead oh I hate when you fall down
I really really really hate dad all
right let's play a little more shall be
oh oh it's like okay that's fine with me
quite find a 9-day Oh Friday sound
suppressor
I felt pretty and wedding and not okay
not that there's anything wrong with
being gay I just done okay keep coming
kids I got this
why did you tell Vince that I was
wasting my oil say now it's your fault I
did yeah I can't be mad at you look at
it stop distracting me says they stopped
it stop doing that
stop picking your nose it's probably not
doing that all right
hustle cool Hey how would that do what
the hell is that doing
oh god you gotta be kidding me
without Anna cooling system I really bit
Tom but I have to press the orange baton
all right it doesn't really look like a
button but I'm clicking it
what the hell did I do
oh [ __ ] I started a shitstorm
midnight that's no bueno
I can't move I'm stuck everything went a
lot better than expected this is pretty
nice and cozy hello alright sweet how it
is I don't like this
no you frakkin kidding me I'm hiding
here if he finds me I swear to god it's
the best hiding spot ever hi teach me
how to be a pipe
what are you doing dangling up there
stop dancing I press I think we're good
but like videos at the end you hide
subscribe comment your day
come fire at the bro army and I'll see
you next episode on salmon bread no no
no no no no no no no no no no no what is
that what is that Celtic remedy number
forty uh okay
where is the diamond there what is this
penis